salut la team mantallot il ya quelques
jours je vous ai dit sur youtube que
j'allais refaire une true story est
aussi une mentalité à sion par skype
j'ai lu vos commentaires je vous écoute
je commence par la trousse forêt alors
c'est une histoire qui m'est pas arrivé
tout seul ça m'est arrivé avec mon pote
philippe roesch vous savez mon pote
imitateur qui est déjà passé deux fois
en vidéo je sais qu'il y en a qui sont
abonnés à sa chaîne voilà ça s'est passé
avec lui en 2008 en était en ukraine on
avait fait trois villes en ukraine et on
était à bord d'un bateau donc on faisait
tout la cote en fait odessa yalta
sébastopol pour traverser ensuite la mer
noire est allié à istanbul on est arrivé
à quai à odessa c'était la première
ville on est descendu il ya un grand
escalier quand tu descends du poireau
des sacs une statue de richelieu en eau
et là on a été frappée par deux choses
la première chose c'est qu'on entend
souvent dans les bars de la variété
française alors pas forcément la variété
actuelle même si on entend des usages
les trucs comme ça mais beaucoup de
d'edith piaf d'aznavour
et la deuxième chose qui nous a frappés
c'est que les filles était vraiment
sublime les filles et les femmes sont
très belle à odessa y ait une légende
qui dit qui est à le plus belle femme du
monde à odessa bah c'est pas
complètement faux dans mon était un
samedi on a eu la chance d'assister à un
mariage parce qu'apparemment c'est le
samedi là bas c'est des mariages c'est
juste ou c'est complètement incroyable
et les limousines ya tout même s'ils
n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent ils rendent
la chose sublime et les filles il faut
savoir qu'elle se marie très très jeunes
là-bas vers 20 ans elle se marie ce qui
explique aussi qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de divorce je pense quand même
que c'est lié bref c'est pas vraiment le
propos on part dans notre quête habitués
avec philippe c'est à dire qu'à chaque
fois qu'on toucher terre au bout de
quelques jours de mer notre notre
mission c'est trouver un bar pas trop
cher donc pas trop touristique un vrai
bar local et où il ya si possible le
wifi gratuit
c'est même très important en fait le
wifi pour ça on s'enfonce toujours dans
les villes dans les petites ruelles pour
trouver vraiment les endroits locaux et
des fois c'est des endroits un peu
improbable et la halle étage d'un
bâtiment c'est à dire il ya un bâtiment
avec des entrées il ya un escalier et
avec une petite terrasse en haut on voit
un barca l'air hyper sympa hyper cosy
recul est modeste mais très bien décorée
à l'intérieur c'est plutôt cool on
décide d'aller se poser là bas on montre
on s'assied tout se passe bien
la serveuse arrivants passe notre
commande en ukraine c'est assez facile
de parler parce qu'il parle anglais et
ukrainiens et russes a en général et
maîtrise et 3 l'angle assez facilement
voire trois ou quatre langues
là c'est un petit peu différent la
serveuse ne parlait pas anglais est bon
quand on veut quelque chose on arrive
toujours à se débrouiller à se faire
comprendre j'ai des notions de ruz
philippe avec des petites notions en
ukrainien
on se débrouille en common law boissons
on sort les ordis portables on se
connecte la serveuse
on vient avec les boissons pour nous
servir et la ja philippe qui lâche
devant elle juste à côté d'elle à la de
ses yeux [ __ ] il dit cette phrase là
elle a de ses yeux [ __ ] parce que
filippi les marseillais donc c'est à
dire que plus tu 1 c'est un mot de
ponctuation chez eux c'est comme si on
mettait un point où une virgule ou un
point d'exclamation il sort le [ __ ]
comme ce à quoi ils là je vois à
changement d'ambiance direct dans la
salle on n'est pas nombreux on est les
seuls vrais clients le reste de des
copains du patron je pense
ou alors des clients très habitués tous
se crispe un petit c'est cette tendance
qui devient un petit peu de ce que
qu'est ce qu'on fout là déjà alors tel
patron qui était pas très fun c'était
plutôt une armoire qui était au niveau
du comptoir
lui il fait la gueule direct ça commence
à se crisper là la serveuse ça va pas du
tout non plus je vois un peu tous les
signes de la colère sur tout le monde
en plus on avait parlé bien fort et là
je comprends qu'il ya un mot commun
qu'on comprend en français qu'on peut
utiliser là bas et qu'ils aient compris
aussi c'est le mot [ __ ] sauf qu'ils ne
connaissent qu'une signification à ce
mot c'est le sens propre littérale de ce
mot le mot qu'on va dire maintenant pour
lui dire que j'allais dire tout le long
de la vidéo le mot interdit
et là mon gars quand tu es perdu dans le
fin fond de desa et que 10 passes ça et
tu sais que dans une petite ruelle je
loue pas mal famés mais c'est pas
terrible non plus tu te dis il va quand
même falloir la jouer serré quant à tout
le bar la tous les copains du patron qui
te regarde avec un oeil mauvais bon tu
as tendance à réfléchir encore plus vite
je comprends le truc en deux secondes
des excuses très rapidement un philips
qui est en train de se passer et je lui
dis mon fils ou parce que oui je
l'appelle fil oup
j'ai une idée à partir de ce moment là
on a fait nous comme si on comprenait
pas ce qui était en train de se passer
comme si on n'avait rien senti on a
continué à parler en parlant toujours
fort sauf qu'on avait comme règle de m
[ __ ] mais j'ai dit le mot interdit
sauf qu'on avait comme règle de mettre
le mot interdit dans chaque phrase qu'a
tout le temps tu peux me passer le sel
[ __ ] pour que je sorte mes frais de
[ __ ] on le mettait tout le temps et ça
c'était juste pour déstabiliser tout le
monde et qu'il l'entende à tout bout de
champ et ça a commencé à marcher j'ai vu
que patron ils nous regardaient la plus
énervée mais d'un oeil très bizarre donc
là toute la tension était redescendue et
ça c'est déjà mieux que de passer pour
deux cibles pour finir le truc j'ai
sorti un jeu de cartes toujours un jeu
de cartes avec moi quand on se déplace
et j'ai fait un ou deux tours de magie
je me souviens plus à philippe bas 6 2
j'ai fait un premier tour j'ai fait un
deuxième
ce deuxième tour de magie que j'ai vu
que le patron la serveuse tout le monde
est en train de nous regarder et j'en ai
fait signe qu'ils pouvaient venir tu
pouvais se rapprocher avec un grand
sourire je me suis mis alors faire des
tours de magie des tours de cartes alors
on se débrouille et plus ou moins pour
se comprendre
tout en prenant soin de continuer à
placer le mot interdit et régulièrement
dans mes phrases quand je parlais
français
la finalité de cette histoire elle est
drôle parce que on avait réussi à
comprendre qu'on avait créé une tension
n'a réussi à comprendre pourquoi on a
réussi à retourner ça dans un autre sens
jusqu'à la fin on se marrait tous
ensemble et qu'au moment de partir la
dernière tournée le patron nous l'a
offert via on a pris deux tournées et la
deuxième on ne l'a pas payé
il nous en a fait cadeau c'était pas
gagné au moment où philippe a dit
qu'elle avait des supers bosio picking
voilà les mantallot j'espère que cette
tranche de vie vous aura plu si vous en
voulez d'autres et bellick et la vidéo
on va dire je vais garder un oeil sur la
vidéo et le jour où celle ci elle
dépassera les 3000 pouces et bien j'en
ferai une autre comme ça ce sera pas
trop souvent pas trop réguliers et ça
nous fera un compteur et puis racontez
moi dans les commentaires les moments un
peu tendue comme ça que vous avez vécu
les situations qui sont un petit peu à
risque et vous avez réussi à retourner
c'est toujours marrant de lire ça
n'oubliez pas également de vous abonner
en cliquant ici et rendez vous demain
matin à 11 heures le samedi c'est 11
heures ciao
je joue mon spectacle en tournée toute
l'année pour connaître les villes passer
faire un tour sur mon site internet
il ya le lien dans le descriptif